I suppose I had a number of what I might
call a prewriting moments as a kid I
recognize that a pretty early age
certainly I was preteens I noticed that
the school day was enough of the day to
spend with my friends I seem to have a
need to want to be alone even before I
started making almost landscape notes in
a journal even before I started keeping
a journal which happened to me when I
was 14 even before then I hadn't need to
come home from school by myself and to
be in a room by myself or in my
grandmother's garden by myself I I guess
the earliest sign was how much I like
being alone how much I actually needed
to be alone the way you need or I need
exercise or food or a certain amount of
sleep the there was that desire to be
and a comfort at being alone